I think there's no problem at all
because the PLP brought Jeremy into the
contest and we're now having a good and
lively debate about the future of the
Labour Party as we should do but let's
make no mistake about it
labour stands at a crossroads it now
faces a very big decision about its
future future direction the choices we
the Uniting go forward and get back in
touch with the public or we go backwards
and really Labour's got to make now a
big choice about what party it wants to
be going forward and whether we're
serious about winning again and you know
we're gonna have that debate we're gonna
make our decision and then move forward
it's not just mr corbyn's crumpled shirt
that puts him out in front in this
leadership contest it's the policies
that he's espousing I mean it does seem
that this contest is Jeremy Corbyn
versus the other three and that
socialism is something of a dirty word
within the Labour Party these days no I
don't think that's right at all I mean I
agree with him on some things such as
more public control and public ownership
of the railways but I disagree with him
on other things for instance saying that
we should have widespread erine a tional
ization of the utilities I just don't
think that is a priority for the country
the moment I don't think it can be
afforded so we're gonna have our our
agreement and disagreements about
various various things but as I've been
saying throughout this interview jeremy
has brought something distinctive to the
Labour leadership contest it's right
that we're having the debate that we're
having the party though does have to
decide it has to decide you know will
what Jeremy's saying help us get back
towards government I don't think the
part the public will think that that
will be where we're heading if we go for
those kinds of policies because I don't
believe people feel that they are the
right policies for where we are right
now as a country so but we've got to
have this debate let's have it let's
keep it respectful let's keep it
positive as I'm trying to do and then
let's let the party make its choice it
does seem that you're coming perilously
close to the position taken by Tony
Blair that had a lot to the left as
there was in 1979 and you know is akin
to adopting a strategy which says the
electorate is stupid
oh I'm not saying that I'm saying we're
having a good debate in this contest I
said to you just a moment ago I agree
with Jeremy on some things but
not on others and the big point of
disagreement I guess is you need to be
credible in what you're saying you need
to be able to say to people use be able
to look them in the eye and tell them
how your policies will be afforded and
how you can also run run strong public
finances you know if labor doesn't have
economic credibility at the heart of its
message then we won't be in a position
where we're heading back towards
governments are you happy in general
terms of the way in which this this
leadership campaign has been fought up
until now I mean you've talked about the
possibility of a split in the party
there have been accusations of sexism
directed at your camp it doesn't seem
particularly comradely no I'm happy with
the way it's been conducted by and large
it's been a good natured contest all
four of the candidate event Cooper's
accused of sexism before to be honest
and I don't want to dwell on it but I
think it was a it was a completely
ridiculous suggestion given that there
are more women MP supporting my campaign
than any other campaign I don't think it
merited much of a response to be honest
but on the whole as I was saying this
has been a a good-natured campaign where
each of the candidates represents a
distinctive position in the Labor Party
and has had something valuable to say
though the bit I didn't think was well
handled was the whole debate about the
welfare bill last week and that's where
the party got itself into a real mess
but on the whole the contest has been
been a good one labor members are being
presented with a real choice now we are
at a crossroads people really have to
decide now what kind of Labor Party they
want well you did have an ample ample
opportunity when it came to to those
welfare changes being put forward by the
Conservatives for you to take a stand do
you concede no that it was a strategic
mistake to say look if I were leader I
would have opposed this wholeheartedly
however I'm not leader so I'm going to
abstain no I don't actually not at all
because I made my position clear and in
making my position clear the party was
forced to move its position more towards
mine you had a hunting meta that was a
better position that was a better
position than where we started started
out but then I faced a choice you know
did I
from the shadow cabinet lead a rebellion
and raised the risk of our party
splitting well you know what I wasn't
prepared to do that
I am never somebody who is going to
plunge our party into civil war once
you've made a decision as a party you
have to expect unity behind the leader
and behind that position unity is
strength has been the motto that's
underpinned our movement for decades and
I'm never somebody who would put that
unity at risk but having shown loyalty
to the Labor Party I will expect the
same from all of my parliamentary
colleagues when I change Labour's
position to one of outright opposition
to this welfare bill come September
because are you asking for the type of
loyalty that you should when you said it
was a mess referring to the welfare vote
wasn't it the run-up to this vote was a
bit of a mess it's quite clearly it
clear that this is a party now that is
crying out for leadership I mean if that
wasn't a full-blown attack and Harriet
Harman what is that was my view about
the way we handled the whole situation I
stand by it it was but in the end I
didn't repeal and split the party I I
was loyal to the position that the
leader had put put forward and because I
was loyal to it means I am the person
that can unite this party coming out of
this leadership election if you're
putting yourself forward as the unity
candidate how do you substantiate that
given that a vet Cooper's camp has
accused you directly of sexism how do
you bring them back within the vault
well I thought I'd dealt dealt with that
but it's been widely now accepted that
Lord Falconer was misrepresented by The
Times newspaper and I believe they've
actually apologized for that so the the
allegation that came from the other camp
was based on that misrepresentation so
I'm afraid it has no substance
neither one neither a bit so a song
steer the party through the challenging
few years ahead I mean that's pretty
clear that's what he said no we were in
the middle of a leadership election the
people who support each of the
candidates of course will make the case
for why they are supporting any one of
the any one of the candidates that's
what happens when you're in a contest
such as this but what people want to see
as are people going about this campaign
in the right way in a positive way and
throughout this campaign I have been
respectful of all the other
candidates and I've been saying let's
have a positive debate about Labour's
future and you know what I'll be
sticking to that right to the end of
this leadership race because I think
it's very important that we do unite
coming out of it and because of the way
I've conducted myself throughout this
contest I believe I'm the best placed
candidate to do just that
unite our party and here Burnham thanks
for your time